Chúnga tình xung độn ngà của khuyen nè bước sang 1 thủ thứ ba chiến sự giữa anh nước đang theo tháng huy hiệm.
Bộ có phòng ngà thông báo đứa tăng cường cứ khu tấn công và cơ sở năng lượng và nhà máy quân sự.
Tại khả khóc đơn nhé, Jeff Horidgea và một số khu bất khá của khuyen nè.
Chúc khi đó là cửa phòng không ngà cũng cho biết đã đánh chạp 5 khoả bóc thông mình,
một tên lửa hi maus và hơn 8,5 bài không người lạnh, số khuyen nè phòng đi.
Fíu kia cũng ngay sang nha.
Ngà đã mở loại không tích giữ giữa giữa bằng tên lửa và uả vê nhằm vào phòng li.
Rồi thường vong trưa dân thường, cũng lúc, mấy bây không người lấy của khuyen nè cũng được chào là đánh cơm nhảm mấy lọc giấu khuyen xí,
ở vùng li điên quát, một chung những câu sở lọc giấu lỡ nhất của ngà.
Giới phần tinh nhận định, viết hai bên cùng ra tăng tấn công, phần anh nỗ lực dành ưu thế trước một đông,
khi chính sửa có thể chuyển sang dự đạn tiêu hào kéo sài.